on a parlé des réformes sociales le
gouvernement a aussi un autre rendez
vous important dans les semaines qui
viennent
il s'agit du grenelle de l'environnement
qui réunira tous les acteurs de ce
domaine parmi les militants de
l'environnement certains poussent leurs
convictions jusqu'au bout on les appelle
les décroissants parce qu'ils refusent
la croissance à tout prix en limitant
leur consommation
pas de voiture pas de télévision parfois
pas de téléphone ou pas de frigo
nouvelle utopie ou tendances profondes
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé romain mais si laurent des bois
alors ça c'est mon supermarché donc pas
besoin de voiture
pas besoin de congélateurs n'exclut
gidere le supermarché le frigo patrick
baronnet sa femme leur ont dit adieu il
y a trente ans lorsqu'ils sont devenus
objecteurs de croissance
leur credo non à la consommation qui
détruit la planète alors dans leur
village de loire atlantique ces deux
enseignants aujourd'hui retraités ont
construit leur maison dite autonome une
citerne d'eau pluviale des panneaux
solaires une éolienne de 18 mètres pour
produire leur électricité et même des
toilettes sèches au fond du jardin
pendant vingt ans on a réfléchi à notre
mode de vie et on a divisé en gros par
10 mhz consommation d'électricité par 10
de consommation d'eau à peu près aussi
par dix nos déchets dans la maison pas
de frigo
le couple baronnet consomme au jour le
jour le strict nécessaire
pas de surgelés ou de conserve car ils
n'ont rien de superflu
on peut vivre avec peu d'argent nous
actuellement avec 700 entre 700 et 900
euros
on a et roy pour voir ce qui est encore
possible d'acheter ce qu'il est mais
nécessaire et que je ne peux pas
fabriquer voilà et le reste est ce que
j'en ai vraiment vous
à paris aussi la décroissance a fait des
émules vincent et adeline du loup jeunes
trentenaires ont sauté le pas il ya
quatre ans à l'origine la découverte de
l'alimentation bio moi j'étais chef de
projet dans le dic est maintenant je
suis fâché des études pour devenir
diététicienne rien à voir ils ont dit
adieu à leur téléphone portable dit stop
à la voiture mais dans l'appartement
tout le confort moderne
c'est sur l'habillement par exemple
qu'ils mettent en pratique leur théorie
- du polo jean jusqu'au basket de jeunes
créateurs se lance dans la mode éthique
et on adore ça qui pour gilad est
souvent les vide greniers nous
permettent d'acheter des vêtements
second choix s'est vite d'acheter des
vêtements tout neuf
souvent très polluants dans les grands
magasins pour ce jeune couple aucune
difficulté à devenir des croissants même
quand on vit à paris et on a la chance
d'avoir des boutiques biologique au
niveau de la nourriture en bas de la
maison un peu partout dans paris
koné solutions sont sous la main et et
c'est vraiment super simple de l'est
sont emparés
comme les familles du loup baronnet ils
sont quelques centaines de foyers en
france
opposé à la consommation à tout prix
visionnaire ou rétrograde avis très
partagés pour les spécialistes
si tous les humains vivaient comme des
français une seule planète terre ne
suffirait pas il en faudra au minimum
trois autrement dit la croissance
économique
ce n'est pas la solution la croissance
économique s'est plus de pouvoir d'achat
c'est plus d'emplois
c'est plus de salaire pour les français
donc il ya une attente aujourd'hui de
croissance le sang bleu team sur le
chemin de la décroissance certains
adoptent la méthode des petits pas
exemple à paris la quarantaine d'amap
association pour le maintien d'une
agriculture paysanne
un petit groupe de personnes qui payent
un paysan pour avoir chaque semaine leur
panier de légumes
chacun à leur manière ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux à vouloir consommer
moins pour vivre mieux